d'accord d'accord un à la fois d'accord
prêt partez 1983 il s'agit d'un groupe d'enfants qui
traînent et l'un de leurs meilleurs
amis va manquer ce gars comme
court dans un couloir sacré tu sais qu'il se passe quelque chose
oh mon dieu je suis coincé
comme horrible  chef de la police, il a un
canapé et il est comme ivre tout le temps
les enfants trouvent cette jeune fille chauve sa
tête rasée elle n'est pas chauve nous lui avons
demandé si elle savait qui il est mais
elle ne donne pas d'informations il se passe
beaucoup plus que  juste lui
manquant quel genre de danger danger dangereux
juste un pied de biche mais bon elle est comme
vous le savez, aucun ami ne vous commande
Steve Harry devient tout ce qu'elle est si
sacrément charmant mais Jonathan est vraiment
cool barb disparaît Nancy et
Jonathan les équipes d'équipe pour essayer de comprendre
ce qui est  aller dans
le comté de maman oh ouais ils pensent qu'ils
trouvent le corps pas le gars en caoutchouc le
caoutchouc pour le haut du corps mais l'autre fille
la fille disparaît depuis longtemps
l'enfant qui va manquer sa mère de
cinq enfants  communique comme le sien à travers la
lumière et il s'avère qu'il a en
fait été emmené dans une autre dimension et
ils essaient d'aller les trouver Je suis Nancy
finit par aller dans l'arbre dans le
monde dans lequel ils vont penser à l'
envers qui devrais-je honnêtement  nous
avons un peu de mal à expliquer que nous
traversons beaucoup de choses et
affrontons la gloire du diable
de son sac Malcom Ross
ensemble et ce qui est arrivé à 11, elle a
juste raté le papier que nous avons là-bas
mais nous avons des œufs dans la boîte
Je pense que j'ai beaucoup risqué
[Musique]
toi